[Musique]
elle n'est pas encore considérée comme
étant officiellement en danger pourtant
à certains endroits en amérique du nord
la crécerelle enregistre un déclin
alarmant dans d'autres régions toutefois
elle se porte mieux
quel avenir donc pour le plus petit des
faucons marie claude martin est
technicienne en biologie à l'université
laval
elle accompagne aujourd'hui deux
étudiants il ne s'agit pas de travaux
pratiques dans le cadre d'un cours mais
une activité choisie par les étudiants
eux-mêmes
catherine barma et david du show sont
membres de la wildlife society une
organisation née aux états unis dans les
années 30 pour aider à conserver les
milieux naturels et la fonde
on est parti leur projet principal c'est
le suivi de 35 nichoirs dont celui ci
situé à saint-apollinaire près de québec
l'oiseau qu'ils étudient est la
crécerelle d'amérique le plus petit
faucon du continent
[Musique]
on la voit souvent perchés sur les fils
ou les poteaux le long des routes
elle est facile à identifier grâce à son
dos rond elle mange des insectes des
couleuvres et même de petits mammifères
la crécerelle niche partout en amérique
du nord et hivernent dans le sud du
continent
elle n'est pas considérée menacée mais
les données sont inquiétants selon une
compilation américaine il aurait
aujourd'hui deux fois moins de
crécerelle que dans les années 60 une
perte de 50% dans nord du canada
ces cinq fois moins une perte de 80 %
au québec les relevés indiquent une
baisse moyenne de 38% ya encore 3 e
cette année on a trouvé que des oeufs
mort son poids que les étudiants ne
magron pas d'oiseau cette année bat
c'est une petite déception mais au moins
on sait que les nichoirs sont utilisés
un peu plus au nord près de saint marc
des carrières dans le comté de portneuf
roland hamel a plus de succès
c'est un agriculteur à la retraite
depuis une vingtaine d'années il
entretient le réseau de nichoirs mis en
place par un de ses cousins dans les
années 50
celui ci a été installée il ya quinze
ans et il a toujours abrité une famille
à l'intérieur une femelle en train de
couver elle ne réagit pas comme si elle
était habituée aux visites
roland un mail vient régulièrement la
voir il connaît bien les habitudes des
crécerelle à quelle fréquence elles
viennent nourrir leur petit par exemple
il constate que le nombre de petits
baisse constamment depuis 20 ans roland
hamel est convaincu que l'agriculture
intensive nuit au crécerelle les viandes
période où ils nourrissent beaucoup et
des mulots si vous retrouvez en forêt
mais quand on commence à voir la
sauterelle te des forces de vente déjà
robert n'aurait section ce nichoirs est
situé justement dans un champ de soya
les oeufs sont infertiles du mois sa
fermette et ont vu la même motion
merlebleu des femelles inversèrent
dépendent l'emporter j'ai vu ici 3e qui
ont peut être que va donner le deuxième
nichoirs qu'il nous montre est lui aussi
dans un champ de cultures annuelles
il y en a combien d'années bientôt ils
devraient survivre les 3 en principe oui
mais ces travaux quand je dis quand on
est prêts dès que le industriels les
porter son taux vos pubs 7
le troisième nichoirs est situé lui dans
un champ pratiquement abandonné où il
n'y a eu aucun et pendage aucun travail
du sol
ici les nouvelles sont meilleures
no 5 sa plus belle ni fait un milieu
naturel champ de foin simplement pas
d'arrosage en tracteur dont on soit à
wade à roanne manque partout mais de
mois en mois on annonçait s'adresse
[Musique]
les intuitions de roland hamel sont tout
à fait plausible on sait déjà que
certains insectes ic2 diminue la
fertilité des rapaces
on sait aussi que les crécerelle
dépensent moins d'énergie quand elle
chasse à partir d'un perchoir
or plus le chant est grand - il ya deux
poteaux enfin la crécerelle chasse au
sol et dans un champ de maïs les proies
sont bien moins accessible que dans un
champ de foin cette couleuvre par
exemple
c'est d'ailleurs dans la plaine du saint
laurent là où il y a le plus de cultures
annuelles sarcler et aspergée de
pesticides que le déclin le plus marqué
au québec
ici le nombre de cris srl a chuté de 75%
en 50 ans
[Musique]
le contraste est frappant avec l'abitibi
plus au nord en abitibi elle se porte
relativement bien comme la majorité des
autres régions du nord du 47e parallèle
au québec on voit pas de baisse marquée
dans ces régions loto québec en abitibi
il n'y a pas de champs de maïs ou de
soya à cause du climat et il reste
encore beaucoup de pâturage
[Musique]
marion c'est guy et son professeur louis
un beau ont voulu savoir quelles étaient
les environnements les plus propices
pour les crécerelle en abitibi ils ont
suivi un réseau de 300 nichoirs les
résultats sont surprenants l'écrit srl
d'abitibi préfère niché près des champs
mais elles ont moins de petits dans cet
environnement que dans les jeunes forêts
comme si elles avaient gardé leurs
anciennes habitudes
même si le chant n'était plus le
meilleur endroit pour elle les champs de
foin ont en effet changé depuis 50 ans
les fauchages sont plus fréquents
effectivement les milieux écoles sont
perturbés au moment où les jeunes sont
sont en plein dans leur message de l
élevage dans les forêts en ré générer
100 sont bien plus tranquille
et quand les arbres sont encore très
jeunes les proies au sol sont
accessibles
avec les années la crécerelle en abitibi
deviendra peut-être noiseau de plus en
plus fort esti elle devrait se tirer
d'affaires mais au sud dans la plaine du
saint laurent
les nichoirs ne suffiront probablement
pas freiner le déclin le coût écologique
de la monoculture est énorme et
insidieux c'est toute la chaîne
alimentaire qui souffrent en silence
de l'insecte jusqu'au crécerelle
[Musique]